des vidéos avec des policiers diffusées
sur les réseaux sociaux elles sont de
plus en plus nombreux c'est à la demande
des syndicats le ministère conduit donc
une étude juridique pour restreindre les
modalités de leur diffusion cela pose la
question de la sécurité des forces de
l'ordre faut-il rendre anonymes les
visages des policiers lors de la
diffusion de vidéos ou ses vidéos son
talent contraire un rempart contre
d'éventuelles bavures ces d'objets de
notre face à face ils pourront débattre
ce soir nous sommes avec mohamed guedha
photographe de terrain bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous à ses côtés stanislas
godon secrétaire général adjoint du
syndicat alliance police bonsoir soit
stanislas godon merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france vous êtes
justement l'un des syndicats très en
pointe sur cette demande de d'anonymiser
ne m'aurait pas facile à dire
le visage des policiers d' éviter de
diffuser voilà sur les réseaux sociaux
ces vidéos de jeunes ans dont christophe
castaner qui envisage de contrôler la
diffusion de ces vidéos vous êtes
satisfait justement qui est une réponse
du ministre même si les choses ne sont
pas encore fait
on va être très prudent parce que les
choses effectivement ne sont pas encore
faites elles sont pour l'instant au
stade de l'année juridique puisque le
texte est complexe à mettre en place
il fait partie notamment des
modifications de la loi de 80 donc c'est
vrai que c'est pas facile mais c'est
néanmoins nécessaire pour l'ensemble de
mes collègues parce que il faut pas
oublier que non seulement parfois on a
des spécialistes qui viennent filmer au
coeur notamment de l'événement ça
perturbe parfois l'intervention
policière et puis surtout le plus
important je crois c'est qu'il faut pas
oublier que les policiers
ils subissent souvent des attaques
parfois certains ont à leur domicile
notamment des lettres de menace pour eux
pour leurs familles donc je crois qu'il
est nécessaire quand même de les
protéger
ces policiers surtout que le fait de
montrer leur visage n'apporte absolument
rien puisque s'il devait y avoir une
enquête pour quoi que ce soit pour
quelques raisons que ce soit en fait il
y aurait des saisines notamment des
vidéos et elles seraient exploités de la
même manière que si elle n'avait pas été
floutés donc ce que vous voulez éviter
pour bien qu'on comprenne c'est la
diffusion sur internet du tout à chacun
qui pourrait voir ses vidéos mais en
tout cas évidemment pas empêché la
justice en tout cas légers peine de s'en
servir pour d'éventuelles enquêtes c'est
bien car ce n'est pas le sujet le
j'essaie de protéger réponse est non
mais c'est pour ça que bon mediapart a
fait un article qui est un peu un peu
polémique notamment par rapport à son
titre mais bon on a l'habitude en tout
cas nous dans les propos qu'on a tenu
notamment dans lors de cette interview
ils sont extrêmement claires nous sommes
pour l'anonymisation des policiers par
rapport à leur exercice de fonction dans
le cadre régalien de l'état et notamment
lorsqu'ils sont sur la voie publique
voit tout simplement
stanislas go dont vous vous êtes
justement un trouble-fête entre
guillemets ça ni sa seconde et voilà il
y avait des gens qui filme au milieu des
manifestations vous faites partie de ces
gens qui fument vous êtes reporters de
terrain vous avez participé à de
nombreuses manifestations photo appareil
photo à la main caméra à la main
cette demande de la part des policiers
vous la trouvez tout même légitime ou
elle vous fait mal mais chacun peut
parce que je pense qu'il n'y a pas
vraiment de risque en fait pour les
policiers c'est par eux qui sont mises
en danger en fait dans les
manifestations au contraire en fait nous
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
environ films pour lesquels moi moi au
départ je prenais des photos j'étais
photographe manifestations et au bout
d'un moment pour
pour notre sécurité aussi on s'est dit
mais en fait il faut qu'on montre ce qui
se passe est une vidéo est plus parlante
en fait est bon comme s'est mis à filmer
parce que je ne veux pas que cueillez
d'impunité en fait c'est ça le la raison
pour laquelle en film stanislas baudot
qu'est ce que vous répondez c'est
intéressant parce qu'effectivement vos
points de vue sont totalement opposés
vous vous mettez en avant la sécurité
des policiers
mohamed des femmes parle effectivement
de peut-être de bavures d'impunité et
c'est pour cela qu'il faudrait fils mais
qu'est ce que vous les réécouter la paix
unité n'existe pas dans nos rangs
d'abord parce que les policiers sont
durement sanctionné je rappelle quand
même juste quelques chiffres 2030
sanction disciplinaire à l'encontre des
policiers nous représentons plus de 50%
des sanctions disciplinaires de la
fonction publique alors que nous
représentons que 7% de la fonction
publique elle-même
donc il y a cinq organismes de contrôle
c'est difficile quand même de passer au
travers
et puis dernière chose à l'heure
actuelle les vidéos qui sont notamment
instrumentalisé qui condamne d'ailleurs
les policiers avant même qu'il y ait des
enquêtes souvent ne reflète pas la
réalité sont sortis de leur contexte
et puis plus grave elle jette je dirais
la vindicte populaire à la vindicte
médiatique des réseaux sociaux notamment
les policiers leur famille également il
faut pas l'oublier donc nous on reste
sur cette position sur le fait qu'il
faut aussi protéger les policiers et
leurs familles parce que lorsque vous
voyez votre visage sur tous les réseaux
sur toutes les vidéos et que vos enfants
les voient également et que le policier
parfois il est dans une légitimité de l'
usage de la force légitime parce que
souvent on confond c'est pas parce qu'un
policier fait usage de la force qu'il
est forcément dans le cadre d'une d'un
dysfonctionnement ou d'un usage de la
force
hors cadre réglementaire il faut pas
oublier que il ya un contexte alors nous
on avait saisi notamment la ministre de
l'intérieur c'est très intéressant parce
que c'était juste avant tout les
manifestations des gilets jaunes voyez
donc ça n'a pas de rapport avec
notamment le contexte que l'on connaît
depuis 66 samedi notamment
et justement c'est intéressant mohamed
gay faf ont dit ces sorties du contexte
c'est vrai que c'est le reproche qu'on
peut faire parfois ces vidéos on voit la
dernière scène où on a les policiers qui
frappe le manifeste on ne voit pas tout
la scène tout le contexte qu'est ce que
vous répondez d'abord j'aimerais
répondre par rapport à un fait c'est
vous avez dit que les policiers ont peur
pour leur sécurité quand ils sont chez
eux et c'est moi j'aimerais juste vous
rappeler la ce visuel qui a été fait par
le syndicat alliance où justement il
montrer directement journalistes à boire
et c'est qu'enfin je comprends pas c'est
quoi c'est un appel il ya marqué que tu
as boivent sachent que notre collègue
n'est pas seul
eq alliance police nationale est à ses
côtés c'est moi moi j'ai l'impression
que c'est plus une menace en fait vous
agissez en tant que corps pour vous
protéger et qu'en est il de la liberté
de la presse
voilà moi ça me questionne là et moi
j'ai plus peur pour ce journaliste
d'ailleurs
au moment où il est sorti cette affiche
un jour après je crois son adresse a été
publiée dans des réseaux d'extrême
droite sur facebook et a donc moi c'est
plus pour lui que j'ai peur en ce moment
plutôt que pour les policiers qui
d'ailleurs sont sans armée après votre
question c'était par rapport au contexte
pour moi le contexte d'une vidéo
lorsqu'il a une violence qui est
flagrante en fait les les
les images parlent en fait quand il ya
des images qui tournent beaucoup c'est
que c'est quelque chose qui même
contextualiser est extrêmement violent
et injustifiables en fait et pour moi en
fait c'est un faux argument c'est oui
mais ils l'ont bien cherché
c'est cette rhétorique elle est très
compliqué à la défendre parce que la
police elle est là pour répondre à des
illégalismes elle est là pour répondre à
des situations de délits donc c'est pour
ça qu'on l'a créé et si tout le monde se
comportait bien il y aurait pas besoin
de police donc si la police existe c'est
uniquement pour répondre de manière
pacifié de manière proportionnée à ces
actes qui sont qui peuvent être violents
que ce soit en manifestations ou ou
ailleurs d'ailleurs donc moi pour moi le
raisonnement à avoir c'est pas
il y à des violences policières
parce que il y à des actes qui ont été
violents juste avant c'est pas comme ça
qu'on doit poser les choses pour moi
c'est parce qu'il y à des actes violents
que la police est créée et qu'elle doit
répondre de manière réglementer de
manière carré et dans le cadre du droit
à ces illégalismes justement c'est très
intéressant ce que vous dites parce que
vous montrer une image mais oui on
défendra à chaque fois qu'il y aura des
personnages qui prôneront de la haine
anti fiq et notamment sur des espaces
médiatiques nous défendrons évidemment
les policiers ça que les chaussons
explique sur cette affaire lui c'est
quelqu'un qui prenait très clairement la
haine anti-flic donc évidemment qu'on a
on a répondu quant à communiquer après
vous parliez de quelque chose de très
intéressant c'est le laisse percer le
fait que ad'abord violence policière me
permettais les ont déboîté l'épaule
alors que cet article deux côtés il
entré dans la voie de la violence
policière
d'abord ne veut rien dire parce que
celle usage de la force soit il est
légitime soit il ne l'est pas s'il ne
l'est pas s'il ne l'est pas légitime et
bien dans ce cas là il fait l'objet de
procédures et il y à des sanctions et
d'ailleurs je le redis dans notre
corporation il n'y a pas deux il n'y a
pas d'impunité
par contre vous parliez de l'usaj de
l'agencé vous disiez mais non on ne doit
pas répondre à de la violence mais la
riposte fait partie du cadre
règlementaire des policiers parce que
lorsqu'on jette un cocktail molotov ou
un triple d'elliot oppose la tête des
policiers ils répondent
et effectivement dans le cadre du
maintien de l'offre puisque c'est ce que
vous
avait l'air de citer le maintien de
l'ordre pour rétablir l'ordre public
après les sommations durable
effectivement il peut y avoir des usages
de la force parce que il faut rétablir
l'ordre et qu' on ne peut pas laisser
les scènes d'insurrection et tout le
monde en conviendra que nous avons vu
notamment le premier le 8 décembre et je
je je je trouve que dire que les
policiers réagissent alors qu' il n'y a
pas forcément de raison c'était pas vrai
je vais vous donner un exemple très
concret 16 mars 2010 9 avenue des champs
elysées c'était quasiment l'insurrection
sur l'avenue des champs et puis à trois
kilomètres de là il y avait la manif
pour le climat 50000 personnes
pas une insulte pas un crachat et
évidemment il ne s'est rien passé
donc vous voyez le contexte est vraiment
très différent et c'est pour ça que je
dis que c'est très en vue dans notre
style boyish justement sa nuit quoi ce
qu'on vous dit ça dit que les policiers
ils interviennent dans un cadre
réglementaire et que lorsque une
manifestation lorsqu'une situation
dérape pas ce qu'on peut pas parler que
du maintien d'ordre est aussi parfois
des interpellations qui se passe pas
bien évidemment lorsqu'on commet un
outrage rébellion lorsqu on résiste on
attaque les policiers alors qu'ils font
leur travail
effectivement il y a une réponse des
policiers
bien sûr qu'il ya une réponse parfois
par usage de la force parfois par à
menottage un peu un peu fort mais c'est
le contexte c'est aussi le métier de
policier
et c'est bien pour ça que cela les
expose jeu relevé surtout par rapport à
la marge du climat qui était calme une
autre manifestation de l'autre côté ça
veut dire que il y aurait selon vous en
tout cas si je vous suis une forme de
provocation dans ses autres
manifestations
alors ce ne sont pas des provocations ce
sont des attaques en règle mais des
professionnels parce qu'il faut pas
mettre tout le monde d'accord mettre
dans le même panier c'est à dire que il
y à des personnes qui venaient
légitimement manifester et des gilet
jaune mais ça il n'y a pas de souci
là-dessus par contre il y avait des
individus des ultras radicaux peu
importe droite gauche c'est pas ça le
sujet mais qui viennent et qui sont des
spécialistes
du désordre spécialiste du chaos on en a
vu certains s'organisent et évidemment à
visage dissimulé c'est pour ça que nous
on était très contents lorsque la loi
anti-casseurs notamment été promulguée
on regrette quand nous est pas donné la
peau la possibilité de prononcer des
arrêtés d'interdiction notamment de
manifester à l'encontre des individus
ultra violent parce que on aurait pu au
moins les écarter et assister peut-être
à des manifestations nettement plus
calme
mohamed gueye vous les avez vu vous
devez aux propres yeux justement vous
dites ces gens qui sont venus attaquer
en règle les policiers nous c'est
quelque chose que vous en tant que
témoin de ces manifestations vous
contestez c'est pas quelque chose que je
conteste qu'il y ait des dégradations
des violences pendant les manifestations
mais cette cet argumentaire en fait est
très fortement contredit par le
mouvement des gilet jaune qui au départ
était un mouvement pacifique en fait
c'étaient des gens qui sont venus
marcher sur les champs-elysées alors
peut-être que s'était pas déclarée mais
ils n'étaient pas venus en découdre
directement et ils ont subi directement
c'était le 24 novembre j étais des tirs
de l bd du lacrymo on a tous l'image de
cette personne les bras comme ça écarte
et qui se prend un tir de la bd dans le
ventre il faisait rien en on a vu
énormément des gens qui ne faisait rien
ou qui étaient juste là en tant que
manifestants qui se prenaient des coups
et et ça montre qu'en fait cette
violence elle peut naître elle peut
naître parce que oui la semaine d'après
le 1er décembre
les gens ne sont pas venus avec le même
esprit que l'arc de triomphe les
dégradations
du patrimoine national l'arc de triomphe
par des manifestants vous l'avez vu ça
aussi
oui exactement les gens sont venus avec
des certains avec des casques avec des
lunettes de protection avec des masques
parce que la semaine dernière il
connaissait pas de lacrymo il savait pas
ce que c d et là ils s'en prennent ils
disent mais c'est pas possible que ce
qu'on a fait pour subir sa est la
violence et elle n'est de ça en fait
elle est créée c'est une réaction à un
comportement policier qui peut être
parfois disproportionnée et injuste en
selle ces manifestants ont dégradé l'arc
de triomphe parce que il avait subi des
violences une semaine d'avancé ça je
pense qu'il ya une colère collective qui
monte et qui a été vraiment vraiment
agrandi par les violences qui ont été
commises le 24 novembre la semaine
d'avant
c'est très intéressant de parler du 24
novembre parce que le 24 novembre
c'était le premier et dernier et vous
savez qui s'était le premier et barney
c'est un policier parce que le policier
il avait pris notamment un engin
incendiaire et il n'a toujours pas
retrouvé d'ailleurs l'usagé de son oeil
alors voyez il faut essayer de faire
attention lorsqu'on essaye d'expliquer
notamment le cadre du maintien de
l'ordre
dire que les policiers ont été les
premiers à faire usage de la force des
caisses d'âcre image n alors qu'il ne se
passait rien alors ça c'est tout
simplement ne pas dire la vérité parce
que si la manifestation où le
rassemblement qu'ils soient déclarés ou
pas les limites c'est pas le sujet même
si il y aurait beaucoup à dire
eh ben vous voyez les policiers il reste
aux abords de la manifestation ils
essaient de contrôler parfois d'empêcher
que des individus pénètrent dans le
périmètre avec notamment des armes parce
que ça aussi on l'a vu et il faut voir
les photos que des matériels qu'on a
saisi notamment à la fois sur des
personnes est à la fois dans des
véhicules qui se rendait sur la capitale
donc d'où l'intérêt de d'avoir ces
contrôles préventifs et de laisser la
police faire son travail sereinement
mais je crois que là on s'éloigne un peu
du sujet de filmer les policiers ou pas
rémy rené encore dans le débat
de la violence la violence elle vous
savez usage de la force par les forces
de sécurité elle n'existe que s'il se
passe quelque chose s'il ne se passe
rien les policiers restent bien
évidemment dans l'encadrement strict de
la manifestation ou du rassemble un
justement stanislas au volant j'allais y
revenir dans ce débat selon des
informations toujours recueillies par
mediapart un need u serait en cours pour
rendre obligatoire justement le floutage
des forces de l'ordre est ce que c'est
ça précisément que vous vous demandez ça
vous suffirait ce floutage comprendre
vraiment à l'onu les policiers l'année
mais je souris continue finalement
diffuser les vidéos vis que cette droite
contexte chacun effectivement de
diffuser sur internet les images que
l'on souhaite aujourd'hui déjà protéger
la personnalité du policier se serait
déjà un pas comme ça se fait d'ailleurs
pour certains services un peu
particulier au sein de du ministère de
l'intérieur ne serait ce que pour
protéger les policiers puis leur famille
je le redis je crois que c'est important
et je crois que tout le monde le
comprendra
et peut-être que ça mettrait aussi un
coup d'arrêt à giresse cet emballement
médiatique sur les réseaux sociaux où on
condamne un peu vite et parfois
l'histoire n'est pas tout à fait celle
qu'on raconte dans les réseaux sociaux
notamment et mohamed de schaaf
oui je pense que la police se protègent
déjà assez l'organisent elle organise sa
protection notamment par la complaisance
des groupes de police par rapport au
fait d'afficher leur et rio ou pas quand
vous allez en manifestation je sais pas
si vous allez encore beaucoup mais une
très grande partie des policiers n'ont
pas leur est rio d'affiché ski c'est un
numéro en fait c'est un numéro qu'ils
sont censés avoir au niveau de la
poitrine qui est
leur identification en fait qu'ils aient
leur identification qui nous permet en
fait de savoir déjà qu'ils sont
policiers et de pouvoir s'il y a des des
actes illégaux de pouvoir justement
retrouver ces policiers
vous parliez de la loi anti-casseurs
tout à l'heure beaucoup de policiers
sont cagoulés en manifestation sans
cagoule et sans et rio sans brassards de
police ce qui rend complètement
impossible à la police ou à l'igpn ou à
tout ce que vous voulez de les retrouver
et donc de punir donc vous vous parlez
de du fait que les policiers sont
extrêmement puni extrêmement voilà les
chiffres nous montrent tout le contraire
par rapport aux mouvements des gels et
jaune ait eu plus de quatre cents 400
plaintes déposées à l'igpn combien de
condamnations quasiment nulle alors là
vous oubliez de dire quelque chose c'est
que les policiers en est triple sanction
ils ont des sanctions judiciaires
administratives et les sanctions sur la
carrière donc dire que il n'y a pas de
sanction il y en a deux mille trente
parents c'est à peu près le chiffre d'un
point de vue administratif
alors après vous parlez du r et o alors
c'est très intéressant parce que le r et
o effectivement on peut pas le mettre
sur des unités de maintien de l'ordre
lourde puisque les gilets
ne peuvent pas être doté notamment des
scratchs et de toute façon avec le gilet
tactique qu'ils ont et tout
l'harnachement notamment du matériel
pour les armes de force intermédiaire
c'est très compliqué c'est l'application
oui oui d'accord mais c'est une
obligation mais après je vous inversion
pas la charge de la preuve
non là parce que en plus souvent il ya
des vies des policiers qui sont un
visage dissimulé ils sont pas visage
dissimulé ils sont avec parfois
effectivement c'est sous les masques la
kpop contre le crâne lacrymogènes mais
ça ça fait partie de leur matériel
d'équipement qu'elle est black dog
souvent alors la police est là pour
répondre à des actes illégaux
si la police commet elle même des actes
illégaux qui va répondre à ces actes là
c'est ça la question que l'on peut se
poser en fait on fait bon si vous voulez
défendre les black block c'est très bien
c'est ça c'est votre droit
je m'étais cas là vous êtes en train
d'expliquer que des policiers ils sont
cagoulés comme les black blocks et qui
devrait subir les mêmes conséquences que
les policiers ne sont pas prêtes le veut
pas porter enfin c'est la c1 c'est mon
sens
en fait vous êtes dans dans la recherche
en fait de la preuve aidé l'accusation
de manière constante vis-à-vis des
policiers mais en fait est ce que vous
savez ce qui se passe dans un maintien
d'ordre ce que vous savez que sur un
parcours par exemple de 3 km lorsque les
policiers interviennent à un endroit
c'est qu'il ya parfois des raisons
parfois c'est qu'il ya une rue adjacente
parce que vous avez un groupe à risque
qui arrive et que vous êtes obligé de
séparer la manifestation ça s'est
produit notamment
il n'y a pas longtemps parce de la
république vous n'avez pas la vision
notamment du cadre du maintien de
l'ordre puisque c'est visiblement le
sujet qui vous intéresse le plus mais on
peut en parler très longuement le
maintien de l'ordre
moi j'ai fait quinze ans de matières
north donc je sais un peu comment ça se
passe et je sais à quel point les
manifestations aussi leur visage a
changé parce que là dedans
oui oui depuis depuis quelques années là
on a des groupes à risque qui s'organise
et qui ne sont pas là seulement pour
cassé une vitrine seulement pour dégradé
un véhicule
ils sont là pour organiser notamment les
attaques en règle vis-à-vis des forces
de sécurité et après ce que l'on oublie
de dire c'est que ces groupes très
spécialisés savent très bien utiliser
notamment les manifestants pacifiques
comme des boucliers et ce qui d'ailleurs
rend très complexe la tâche du maintien
dehors des du rétablissement de l'ordre
public
parce qu'il faut arriver à séparer les
individus ultra violents notamment des
manifestants pacifiques c'est pour ça
que nous on leur dit lorsqu'il ya des
sommations il faut absolument que les
personnes qui sont dans le périmètre
ces cartes et nous laisse faire c'est
comme ça par exemple que justement les
blessés je n'ai pas les chiffres en tête
effectivement mais voit la preuve est
que ça puisse choquer effectivement là
la population alors oui
après on peut se jeter au visage nombre
de blessés non années 2000 dans le cadre
des 66 manifestation de gilet jaune
enfin qui étaient plus des attroupements
un certain moment mais si il y à de l'
usage de la force qui est paquet pas
réglementaire ça fait l'objet des
sanctions il ya des collègues notamment
qui vont faire l'objet notamment de
passage au tribunal
après le temps médiatique n'est pas le
temps de l'enquète et heureusement que
dans ce pays on recueille tous les
éléments pour mettre en condamnation ou
mètres plus tôt et organiser la défense
aussi des policiers parce que ce sont
aussi des hommes comme les autres et ils
ont le droit aussi au respect de la
présomption d'innocence
vous continuerez vous allez sur les
manifestations à filmer à diffuser vos
images alors je continuerai à y aller je
continuerai je l'espère là je suis en
arrêt maladie parce que je me suis pris
ceci dans la jambe une grenade un
morceau de grenade les violences
policières en tant que
en tant que photographe en tant que
reporter on en subit à toutes les
manifestations
on nous empêche de filmer plusieurs fois
on m'a donné des coups parce que j'étais
en train de filmer justement des
violences plusieurs fois j'ai reçu des
tirs de grenade vers moi alors que nous
étions un groupe de journalistes qui ne
faisons rien de plus que de filmer
justement ces violences là et
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment ça la
question
la police et les syndicats
plus précisément savent que le
gouvernement ne peut rien faire sans eux
ne peut plus rien faire parce qu'il a
énormément de contestation sociale
donc il ne prendra pas de sanctions
fortes et il renoncera chaque décision
qui ira à l'encontre de la police et
c'est ça la réelle problématique qu'on
vit aujourd'hui c'est est ce qu'on peut
considérer qu'on est encore dans une
démocratie ici même nous qui faisons de
l'image en manifestation en est empêché
aujourd'hui je peux pas travailler à
cause de violences que j'ai subie en
fait et on est beaucoup on était 24 la
manifestation du 5 décembre en été
une quinzaine également aux
manifestations du 9 janvier de janvier
ça commence à faire système ça commence
à être dans donc je vous laisse aller
dans les modèles
oui je vous laisse vos propos sur la
théorie du complot vis-à-vis des
policiers après vous parler d'eux
c'est très con de dallas mais ça c'est
concrètes d'accord d'accord c'est très
concret et puis et puis vous vous
évoquez notamment le encore une fois les
âges des armes de force intermédiaire
j'ose espérer que vous étiez bien sûr
identifié comme étant un agent de presse
puisque vous savez que ça c'est possible
georges que les agences de presse ils
ont la possibilité de se faire connaître
notamment auprès de la préfecture de
police puisque c'était le cas avait vu
j'imagine que ça se passait à paris il
il est un cadre un puisque notamment
depuis la fameuse affaire benalla il y a
la possibilité notamment de participer
et de films et bien sûr sans prendre de
risques parce qu'on a aussi ses prêts
sponsable il était là c'est de vous
préserver notamment des attaques
merci beaucoup à tous les deux en tout
cas mohamed guèye a fait samedi 16 go
d'ambès trains venus débattre et c'est
la fin de ce jour